who can hear so I think that without the
mic Cynthia would not be able to hear
questions if you have questions wave and
they'll bring the mic good so in a
better world Cynthia would be here and
giving the talking person but as things
are Cynthia will tell us about measuring
our chances risk prediction in this
world and its batters
uh thank you Omer and um I have really
been enjoying zooming in and listening
to some of the talks they've been
fantastic
um
this Workshop
has its roots in the theory of
algorithmic fairness
and you've used been using the word fair
in lecture after lecture after lecture
but we're losing track a little bit of
some kind of gut feeling of fairness or
Equity that and this has been on on our
minds
so
um here are some examples of risk
prediction on the left uh we're scoring
somebody in power someone who so so this
is sort of indirectly related to equity
because we're scoring the judges on what
might be inequitable Behavior but we're
not really concerned about our scoring
function being being unfair
um
and uh on the right we have
um two very different kinds of examples
uh on the top right we're predicting
something that at this very moment we
cannot affect absolutely no way to
affect it and so inequity is not an
issue in this scenario but in the second
case on the right the lower one inequity
is you know deeply involved in this
question so just kind of keep that in
mind as we briefly review some of the
setup
the thrust of a lot of work has been to
view accuracy as a kind of fairness
um
and we even tend to call Pi star nature
as if it's kind of fixed and embedded
um but chances of success are very often
contextual so somebody's chance of
success in a workplace may depend on
whether the workplace is egalitarian or
misogynistic
um and in fact even who we are our
feature Vector the way the information
about us that that kind of is fed into
the predictor is also contextual and
deeply related to questions of equity so
the whether in in developing we had
clean air and water and good housing and
good education your parents connections
what kind of health care we had access
to all of this sort of deeply affects
Who We Are
so in the rest of the talk I'm going to
use the notation that has been used
often in the last couple of days Pi star
is the real life probability but I'm not
going to call it nature that I will
receive a positive outcome
um oistar is a Bernoulli draw from PI
star which is the real life outcome and
then we have the model probability and
outcomes drawn according to the model
with tilde's on them
okay and in case you've been unconscious
for the last four days
um outcome and distinguishability uh for
predictor f
um uh it says that given a distinguisher
collection a
um no uh distinguisher in the collection
should be able to distinguish real-life
outcomes from those drawn according to f
and
as Michael explained there's a hierarchy
and we're going to be looking at the
second level the sample access oi in
which our distinguisher has access to
the predictions
um
okay
so
kind of the reason we're all here is
that outcome and distinguishability
um outcome indistinguishable predictors
can be constructed given only real life
outcomes data so if there are outcomes
from real life samples of the form i o i
star then there's an algorithm for
creating a predictor that is outcome
indistinguishable from this real life
and the key Point here is that we're
only working on outcomes data
the predictor never sees I mean the the
algorithm to build P Tilda never sees um
the values P star of X and we don't even
know whether these values are
necessarily integer or whether there's
actually uncertainty in the world and P
star of X could be a number between zero
and one
so
our starting point is the fact that
outcome and distinguishability is
descriptive it's not aspirational it's
not trying to get us to a better world
um like changing the fundamentals of
how the success should be viewed and and
and encouraged and so we think about we
want to think about something that we're
calling um corrective transformations
so
that's our topic how do we get towards a
better world or suppose we had an idea
of what would be a way of getting to a
better world what can we do about it
so imagine first that we have a Utopia
and in this Utopia every individual is
completely supported to reach their full
potential and they have adequate health
care and so on and so forth so that's
our Utopia
and so each X has some U star of X the
utopian chance of success
and then
real life
kind of Beats it all out of us so in
real life we have all kinds of horrible
isms we have sexism and we have racism
and we have uh pollution and we have
inequity and we have lack of gender
affirming care and lack of access to
reproductive care and so on and people's
ability to succeed can be distorted
usually for the worse and sometimes
because of privilege of made for the
better
so
um we imagine that there's this horrible
transformation T that takes our utopian
world and beats it down and gives us
what we actually have in real life and
this might be a trend
a transformation that completely
destroys information
um
and there may be no way information
theoretically to get back
from X Prime
to X or even from P star of X Prime to U
star of x
so our starting point is the notion of a
transformed predictor
um we can think of the predictor as a
vector of dimension of the size of our
universe and it's indexed by elements in
the universe
and the transformed predictor is another
Vector of the same length with different
probabilities
and T Tau
uh this transformed predictor operates
on pairs on X P of X producing the
transformed predictions Tau P of x
so these notations are completely
equivalent and sometimes it's just nice
to spell out the P of X and sometimes
it's nice not to have to bother
and in particular
if P star is kind of what's happening in
real life
or in one particular context in real
life
we can imagine a transformation that
operates on P star and gives us a
transformed predictor and this is
mathematically well defined although of
course we can't get our hands on these
numbers we can't even get our hands on P
star of x so and we don't even know if P
star of X has to be integer or not so um
but but but it makes sense sort of
mathematically
so to give you an example suppose in the
first example in a transformed World
scores from members of some group G are
boosted say add point two to the scores
of members of G so formally that would
say that Tau Pi of X is just the Min of
sorry Tau of P of X is the Min of P of X
Plus 0.2 and 1 where X and G and just P
of X of X is not in G so we're only
playing with the values of people in G
um
now our that's um the most simple kind
of transformation but another kind might
be parametrized so uh Tau might be
paired with a learner that learns the
values of the parameters by studying
real life outcomes data so we have a
learner L and it gets samples from The
Real World and it produces some
parameters pi
an example of this is that in the
transformed World scores for members of
a group b are adjusted to ensure
demographic parity I.E that the
probability of a positive outcome will
be the same uh for a random number of a
is for random number of B
so the way that's done is by learning
the base rates
um of a positive outcome for members of
a and members of B and Computing this
value pi and then we can set Tau of P of
x to be P of X of X is in a stays
unchanged and then this convex
combination of Alpha and I'm sorry that
should have been pi and 1 minus pi times
P of x if x is in b
so that's a case where we have some
parameters that we learn
now
there's some uncertainty here you notice
that we have a learner the learner gets
samples
those samples are drawn from a
distribution if we run the learner at
different times we may get slightly
different values
um so so it's not even clear necessarily
how do we fix the specific Tau of Pi Tau
of P if there's a learner involved and
so there's a technicality which is that
we Define something which we call the
canonical transformed predictor and it's
well defined we're taking the
expectation over the randomness of the
samples fed to the learner coins of the
learner and any other Randomness but now
that I've told you about that we're
going to forget about the canonical
uh transformed predictor because it's
just it won't add to our intuition
so where does Tau come from
um well
it's just it's exogenous it might be the
combination of experts and wisdom and
ethics and policy and history and
geography and arithmetic and machine
learning and so on
and for the purposes of this talk
just assume that it has been determined
that for for one reason or another
we would prefer the world Q star which
is defined to be Tau of P star
the transformed world would be a better
world
so our corrective transformation is the
world of Q star
and
we would love to be able to find Q star
but of course we have no data from this
world
and
in some sense you know so so our
question is when can we build a
predictor Q tilde that is
indistinguishable from this better World
Q star
using only real life samples
so we have this transformation T that
took Utopia and moved us to P star Tau
applied to P star will get us to a
better world no reason at all to think
it gets us back to Utopia T was
information destroying but it's still a
better world or a better work
environment
so
we have real life samples from P star
we know that we can build
predictors that are indistinguishable
from P star
we'd love to be able to do the same
thing on the right with Q star but we
have no data from qstar we have no
samples of Bernoulli drawn according to
Q star of X available to us
and so what we're asking is can we even
build a q-tilda that is
indistinguishable from Tao of P star
uh using only real life samples and if
so you know when or what are the
conditions
so in order to answer this we need the
notion of a random instantiation of a
predictor remember that our predictor is
a vector of Dimension size of the
universe
and
um
for every X we'll let P Prime of X be a
draw from the Bernoulli distribution
with parameter P of x
so P Prime of X is necessarily Boolean
whether or not P of X is Boolean
okay now if p is always Boolean there
will only be one random instantiation of
P it's it's a it's exactly P itself but
if p is not sort of uniformly Boolean
there could be many possible random
instantiations of P
and it turns out the key
property
for enabling us to learn something that
is indistinguishable from Q star from
our better world
is the notion of robustness
uh the robustness of
the transformation Tau
to random instantiations essentially
we're looking at the following question
in general does Tower of P look like
what we would get
if we chose first P Prime as a random
instantiation of p and then looked at
Tau of P Prime
so let's just kind of look at this
pictorially on the left
we have X this is the on the left we
have the world of of um
of p and so P of X is just some some
value V
and uh if we look at the random
instantiations
of P Prime of x
we get say U1 for the first random
instantiation U2 for the second u3 for
the third and so on and we know that on
average they're equal to V that's just
the properties of the Bernoulli
so now suppose that Tau of
P applied to X is some value V Prime
and we're asking is it also the case
that when we look at random
instantiations of p and look at what Tau
does to them
and we get these values U1 Prime now U2
Prime and so on and so forth will these
average to approximately V Prime
so if this holds for most X then tau is
robust to random instantiations and if
it doesn't then tau is not robust to
random instantiations
so again random instant robustness to
random instantiation says that Tau of P
looks like Tau of
um random instantiation of p in
expectation
so going back to our examples
on the first one we boosted scores for
members of G
and this is not robust to random
instantiations so to see this suppose
the members of G all have P of x equal
to a half
and so uh here on the left
P of x
is a half and P Prime of X is zero or
one half about half of them are zeros
and half of them are ones
in the satellites the uis
on the other hand if we look at um
what's going on on the right
how P applied to X is 0.7 we took 0.5
and we added 0.2 to it
but on the random instantiations well
half of the random instantiations were
already one and so we can't add anything
to them
um the other half of the random
instantiations are zero so we can add
something to them and so what we end up
with is that we get 0.7 for
um Tau P of X but we get 0.6 for the
average of Tau of P Prime of X over the
different P Primes
so this is not robust to random
instantiations
the demographic parity example is robust
to random instantiation and
in a nutshell this is because with high
probability a random instantiation of P
will yield approximately the same value
for pi
so
when you're estimating your base rates
on the random instantiation versus on P
you get the same thing
and what we find is that robustness is a
complete characterization so informally
if we have a transformation Tau together
with a learner l
um if L comma tau is robust to random
instantiation then there's an algorithm
M for learning uh uh a q tilde which is
outcome indistinguishable from Q star
or any set a of Sam um of sample access
or no access distinguishers
on the other hand if L tau is not robust
to random instantiation then there is
some no access distinguisher a so that
there is no algorithm
for learning
um uh uh EQ tilde that is even no access
indistinguishable from uh Tau of P star
so in the last couple of minutes I want
to tell you a bit about the intuition
for how to prove this
so the exciting case for me is um
sufficiency
so suppose you have a whole bunch of
samples from real life x i o I start
take your samples and we're going to
partition them
now
remember these are real life samples so
the oi stars are Boolean
and
in a strong sense we can look at a bunch
of samples and say oh yes these are in
fact
samples from a particular random
instantiation of P star that's what that
Bernoulli draw is
so we can break our sample collection
into L partitions
and
we can view the first set as samples
from one random instantiation and the
second set as samples from another
random instantiation and so on and so
forth so we have
samples from L different random
instantiations now there's a tiny
technical detail here about what happens
if a feature Vector appears twice
um in in our collection but that's so
unlikely that I'm not going to talk
about it but you know it means you have
to add a negligible to all of the
analyzes
okay
so we have samples from the first random
infatiation second random instantiation
third and so on and so forth We Run The
learner independently on each one of
those and that gives us parameters Pi 1
Pi 2 pi J and so on up to Pi l
so now given more samples from real life
we're going to show how to use these
pies that we've learned to build a St to
build samples for something that's very
close to Q star
so given a sample X Y we're going to
uniformly choose a J from between 1 and
L so we're going to choose one of these
pies
and we're going to Output the pair x z
where Z is drawn according to
the Bernoulli distribution that has
parameter
Tau sub Pi J of PJ of X so we learned Pi
J
IV in pi J we now have a transformed
predictor Tau sub Pi J of PJ and
um
um that uh and so now we have a sample
from there
so
why when we have this pair x y y is a
random instantiation of P star of X and
so again we're setting PJ of x to equal
Y and we evaluate Tau Pi J on X Y to
obtain Tau of P J
Tau Pi J of P J of X okay
so what does that say
because of the way
we chose J uniformly at random
x j is now just a sample from this
distribution the expectation over J
uniformly in L of Tau Pi j p j of x
and now we use robustness to say that
we have a sample
you know basically we have samples from
this term here on the right
and by robustness we know that that's
approximately equal to uh Tau oops Tau P
star of x
so if L is large enough then we can just
use turn off bounds to say that we're
getting something that in X is you know
very likely to be very close to in
expectation Tau P star of X so we have a
way of generating things that are very
close to samples from Q star
um
so that's the positive direction
uh the intuition for necessity is it's
kind of more mysterious in some ways
um but the idea is that if tau is not
robust to random instantiation then by
definition there's a p star and a large
set of elements X for which there's a
big gap between Tau of P star of X and
the expectation for random
instantiations of Tau of the random
instantiation of x
and we use that s to define a level one
distinguisher
so
to my knowledge this is the first work
in the rapidly expanding oimc literature
that
considers prediction for a better world
and we have a complete characterization
for when that's possible and an
algorithm
so the question is what would we like to
do next and one thing is to develop an
understanding of what it is that robust
Transformations can accomplish
um
and another thing that we can do is we
can create a sort of Holodeck we can use
the technology to explore proposed
Transformations that we are considering
and see what would their
what would their results look like
okay
thank you
questions okay
so I had a question regarding the
necessity condition do you have a
conceptual interpretation of
what does this large set of X elements
mean or like especially for the
transformation of just adding 0.2 good
so
um
the fact that we get a difference of
this of the kind shown here is immediate
from the definition
um from what it means to not be robust
to random instantiation
and then
um we can Define two random variables
which looks at like the expectation of Q
tilde of X for X in s when Q comes from
Tau of P star or Tau of P Tau of P star
versus from uh an expected
um over P Prime of Tau of P Prime
and they have to have in these two
random variables have to have nearly
identical distribu distributions
but if multi-accuracy were actually
possible then they would have to have
different distributions because
um uh
because oops because of these this Gap
so
um
so we would so we get a contradiction in
the contradiction comes from the way we
Define the random variables and the way
we get our hands on their values via uh
multi multi-accuracy
so it's a pretty in yeah I don't know
okay another question uh thank you for
your talk I was running and I think
you're maybe getting to it with the last
slide of next steps but I was trying to
kind of understand how we're supposed to
think about using this cute tilde and at
least based on my understanding it's not
something we should deploy immediately
like we have no guarantee that deploying
it will get us closer to this better
World it could potentially even bring it
further away so the what you're saying
is we should kind of use it to explore
what the what world these
Transformations are bringing us to
uh interesting so
um
what I said earlier was that you know
we're going to assume that we have
reason to believe that Q star is a
better world than P star
and
um so we would want to be able
to to
model Q star
and we would and therefore we would want
to be able to build this Q tilde now
to your question is great
um uh
sometimes
I think that people have enough
understanding to know that if they
change things a certain way then the
world really will get better let me
give it for me is a personal motivating
example
um
uh
I was in the first
graduate class at Cornell PhD student
batch at Cornell that was a third women
and
um
the women my year did really really well
and I'm convinced that this is because
we had reached a critical threshold
that crit you know we had critical mass
and I think that uh if you have an
understanding of these kinds of
phenomena and you use that to Define
your Transformations
um
uh you will literally Implement a better
world you'll get to a better world
even the nasty work environments could
be
the nastiness could be mitigated by
having many more members of a minority
group
okay
but uh having said that
I think that um
I think I really mean also my second
bullet which is to sort of like say well
here's a here's a proposed
transformation what would happen if the
world looked like this proposed
transformation
let's study that and see whether we like
it or not
thank you
quick question or
okay thank you very much Cynthia for
joining us
foreign